let's start with a little bit of chit
chat up here on the on the stage just to
just to get things going and we'll be
sure to leave plenty of time for your
questions so you may want to think ahead
to that you've seen the bios of the
panelists in your book so I'm don't need
to belabor the point but I would like
them each to just say a few words by way
of introduction a little bit about your
background and how you got to this point
we'll start at this head and shonda and
move down so I came out of Stanford GSB
directly into venture capital about 20
years ago and eldorado ventures is an
early stage fund we focus on information
technology and we ate extent of what we
do is first round investments and then
we follow them through so everything
from components up through services
consumer as well as enterprise sorts of
opportunities my background originally
was in engineering so I move from
engineering into marketing and then to
graduate school Charlotte must make
pretty unusual to go stay at a business
school intervention I'm somewhat but I
had I had six or seven years before
undergraduate and graduate school so I
had enough work experience and some of
you will remember the bubble in late 90s
there was also a bubble in the early 80s
which wasn't quite as big but had the
same sort of cyclic cyclicality to it so
having been through that I had a better
shot getting a debenture at that point I
actually graduated from Stanford as well
ancient history class 90 and then went
to business school on the East Coast
spent about ten years in Austin getting
involved with to startup IPOs tivoli
systems and then a company I helped
start called motive move back to Silicon
Valley and decided that there was an
unserved market in the VC business
between angels and traditional funds and
so my basic investment thesis is that
500 k is the new 5 million and that
there's a there's a wave of capital
efficient opportunities enabled by
lilburn experimentation and abundance
and technology and I've had a pretty
good run and beginner's luck so far but
no exit
and Mike do you Jeff LPS or I I do yes
okay John John ginger Ola I was rejected
from Stanford Business School several
years ago went on the East Coast we'd
like to reconsider actually going to
bring my rejection letter entrepreneur
by nature started a collection of
companies pre business school I took
time off went went back came back to
California originally a an engineer
building satellites for Lockheed
missiles and space actually spent some
period of time doing as Mike did angel
investing in a collection of startups
some technology some non technology
built a couple of software companies and
recently join or a year ago joined a
company called box if I delivering
speech applications and currently the
CEO of that that venture trucks eagle
and I'm also kind of a career
entrepreneur but in the food business
specifically chocolate I started my
first chocolate company when I was in
business school in Rochester New York
moved out here for a real job within a
year had quit that to start my first
legitimate chocolate company which I had
for seven years before selling it when
my first daughter was born Charles
chocolates is my newest company it's a
chocolate coming by the way there's a
lot of chocolate down here far more than
we need for a group this size so by all
means help yourselves and started that
company just over three years ago here
in the bay area but did not study food
and completely self-taught it's just
it's a business I found myself enjoying
and loving and like I said with a with a
break to do a few calms between my two
chocolate companies it's what I've been
doing for over 21 years so serial
entrepreneurs are rare serial chocolate
on
are you the only one you know uh no I
know one other but but he he's a crazy
Frenchman who had about four traffic
companies over 50 years all right okay
so you can you can see the setup we have
you know we have in in that corner a
couple of folks on the entrepreneurial
side and in this corner a couple of
folks on the financing side and so you
know hopefully through through those
different lenses will be able to get a
couple of perspectives on on the funding
puzzle so I wanted to start down on the
on the entrepreneurial side of the table
and and John maybe you could start and
check if you chime in and the question
is how you think about given the
business you have in front of you or
that you're envisioning how do you think
about a funding strategy and who it is
that is your your ideal kind of
financial investor sure you know I think
and I'll speak from a broader sense not
just my current company because I think
I've been rejected by a collection of
different funding sources I think
there's a couple things to keep in mind
number one you know just want to stick
with the basics you know funding is
staying alive if it's your first round
of funding it's it's your ticket to the
dance you get to play if it's a
subsequent round of funding it is you
know staying alive another day because
every entrepreneur believes that you
know another day I can make something
happen so I think there's a there's
there's two points that I'd make number
one investors fund milestones so I think
the game to me is I look at you know
what tomorrow is supposed to look like I
have a vision of what tomorrow may be
and then the investor looks at that and
says you know that spot there is it a
good spot can you get to that spot if
you get to that spot does it validate
something in your company that allows
you to foot be fundable for the next
phase of your of your plan so so one is
this real idea that investors fun mouse
those every time that I was doing
something I was trying to identify
sort of started with the red dot on the
mall map you are here drew a picture of
where I wanted to be and then said I
need to tell a story about going from
here to there and if somebody believes
it it's a good spot and I can get there
then I get a chance the the second point
that I would make is that I think you
have to match investors to investment
type so let me explain what I mean by
that I've done a variety of things
actually sitting in somewhat in Mike's
chair and the angel investing so I think
I think like an investor but you have to
look at what the company is doing at
that at that point in time is it for
example are you in development phase so
you're trying to determine can I build
this thing is it a pilot or going to
build out your first pilot is it a is it
a you know early market acceptance can
somebody other than a relative you know
actually you know by this thing pay me
cash for it am I in a am I determining
the bif the business model works so is
it my scale test if I grow this thing
you know how old economics of this
company work do I you know I look at the
economic model over time so there's
there's a variety of different tests I
think that you take all the way up to
expansion stage you know the model
already works got a product working
things are happening we'll just add a
little rocket fuel to it so I think you
look at you know a you know what's that
company trying to do and then be what's
the what's the Holte questions to later
be who's the most appropriate investor
for that so and that's it's important
take an example I think there are very
there there are folks that are built to
be early stage investors they understand
the dynamics of that first five guys in
a garage the trials and tribulations you
have in that how difficult it is to do
that first you know 180 days so if
you're a startup with five guys in a
garage you don't go to a late stage
investor if you are in a particular
category for example some of the some of
the groups today look at different that
may have different focuses your ass ass
company it's kind of sexy today if your
ass ass company you might look at a visa
firm that has you know a very good
experience you know in that industry so
you don't have to educate your investors
on the type of business model that you
want to you know pursue so I really do
think that you you know you look at the
type of company that you have the stage
that you're in ask these appropriate
questions and then really match that to
the type of investor that is most
appropriate for that because you really
don't want to spend a lot of time
educating your investors you got it here
you're trying to essentially get in
there with someone who gets it fast
thank you chai I agree with John saying
again actually you take his two points
which I think are probably the most
appropriate and do them backwards we're
a consumer goods company and we're
basically making chocolates so we right
out of the gate we're dealing with a
much smaller pool of potential investors
at least here in the Bay Area then
another style or type of company might
be looking at so for us it was a an
issue of okay we're making a food
product there are only so many early
stage investors that have experienced
enough to properly evaluate what we're
doing beyond while this chocolate tastes
great so for us it was really a strategy
of identifying those investors figuring
out the the clearest path to them and
then getting in front of them the ideal
investors for our first round were
basically angels and our first round was
with the exception of two angel groups
formal angel groups like the Angels
forum for example they were all
individuals but all individuals who were
either successful entrepreneurs and
consumer goods or successful
entrepreneurs who understood
manufacturing specifically so we really
went at it because quite frankly I
didn't have a lot of time to waste
raising money trying to be as efficient
as possible and identifying those people
in terms of funding strategy again to
John's early point it was really about
figuring out how we got basically from
this little 500 square foot kitchen that
we were renting to where we are today in
a 12,000 foot kitchen efficiently and
with a trajectory that an investor could
look at and say this is a
that I can invest in and again if it's
achievable it gives us either enough
scale to be a successful company or it
gives us the scale of necessary to
attract larger investors for be wrong so
we structured the investment basically
against specific milestones again
because we knew that we had to achieve
something in the marketplace before if
you will larger investment firms would
look at us seriously and the consumer
good space it's a little bit more
difficult first not necessarily because
there's a greater attrition rate be cut
but because as a rule the exit
strategies first tend to be a little bit
different and they tend to have a lower
value than a lot of Technology exit
strategies so investors are I wants a
weary necessarily but they evaluate
manufacturing and consumer goods
companies a little bit differently than
say technology companies thank you so my
control I want to answer the same
question from the flip side I mean
there's a there's a ton of filters you
apply when when somebody walks through
the door but what are the filters in
terms of time clanton Angeles's type
this just isn't my kind of business what
what's in the sweet spot for each of you
that I made this a little different
given your in slightly different
approaches here how did you want it yeah
I mean before I will do that before I do
that I did what I can't comment because
I think i think they guys have hit on
something really important this this
investor type question because one thing
i think entrepreneurs often don't
consider is that if you're raising money
you're actually it's a sales process
you're selling your company all right
you're selling shares in your company
and all sales processes are emotional
you all the data and this is especially
true in early stage later stage you know
you got to have more data but no one's
going to look at the data to do the due
diligence and the analysis unless they
fundamentally get hooked so your job is
not repairer is to find first of all to
be efficient find people that are likely
to be hooked by your story hook them
emotionally so they actually want to do
the deal
and then provide them with the data they
need to justify it to themselves and
their partners so it's I think a lot of
entrence don't really look at it that
way they think well this is a funding
thing it's different from selling but if
you're successful in selling a product
or service take those lessons that
you've learned and use that to sell
something that's much more interesting
more intangible more eminently you know
malleable which is the story the vision
of your company so I'll say that so I
think that's and you can save a lot of
time if you do as much homework on your
investors and and target your investor
group in the same way that you target
your prospects you know when you go to
sell a product you want to make sure you
got the buyer who has a budget who has a
need do the same thing with the
investors so in terms of El Dorado I you
know I can't tell you how quickly i hit
the delete button when i get an email it
says I you know okay first of all do you
mr. ballast I am I looked on your selfie
star has a gender comment but same thing
misspelled the guy's name right mr.
Marple looked on your website I think
you are the perfect fit for us we do you
know we'd retail because we don't do
that you know we do retail goods in
South Florida now our website clearly
states that you know we're early stage
investors we like to be close to our
entrepreneurs we're active in
potentially California Texas in
Minneapolis because that's where we have
some partners from originally but Billy
its west coast venture capital that's
what we position we do have portfolio
companies in other places so people find
us there that's fine but what our
messages to the on preneur community if
you're west coast information technology
services are five it's some kind of
technology and able to play and your
early-stage so your first or second
round then you should be coming to talk
to us and if I get it if I get an
entrepreneur or a group that comes in
and says so you know I know you're on
the board of or you or one of your
partners on the board of these three
companies that we think are incredibly
urge istic I you know that such a
little chicken okay this guy did guy or
gal did their homework they know what I
like and they're going to end that and
they're going to
xanthus in a way that is much more
likely to appeal to me and my partner so
okay thank you just one general
observation just from being a former
entrepreneur I found that fundraising is
either ridiculously easy or ridiculously
hard it's binary and so and
paradoxically on the side of investor
now I want somebody to walk in the door
and be in a total position of strength
so so my advice is that you should be so
ridiculously easy to fund that you look
at it like you're hiring your investors
and the problem is that most people
aren't ridiculously easy to fund which
means that it's ridiculously hard to
fund and they haven't done enough work
and preparation proven the business
enough to be able to hire the best
people and so then they get married with
bozo investors and then now all of a
sudden that hurts the business and so my
advice is do what it takes to make it
easy or do more homework but but but I
find that there's no in-between I've
never found it moderately easy to raise
money but what does it take to make it
easy well well I think that that a few
things world-class expertise in an area
and that world-class expertise
translates into a fundamental insight
that's different from the conventional
wisdom but that's provable based on that
expertise another thing that I see that
that distinguishes people is having
accomplished customer development
milestones in addition to product
development milestones too many
companies present an engineering project
is their company plan rather than a how
am I going to get customers and how am I
going to use money to drive the business
and build it forward and so you know
those types of factors everybody has
their own capricious criteria when they
invest but but but those types of things
you know visionary entrepreneur with
unconventional wisdom customer
development fundamental advantage modest
capital requirements are the things
where if proven they get my attention
right away and very quickly I get into a
mode of saying well let's talk about why
you should hire me rather than other
Esther's because we're not going to
spend a lot of time me doing ten times
more due diligence than i should which
is just an excuse for not doing a deal
so I'd like to move on to the you know
the matching question and how do you
find one another right and so from both
perspectives from you know from from
from your side what and maybe we should
start with the entrepreneurs what are
the effective ways of finding sources of
funding and here we're talking about you
know individual firms individual angels
it's a very daunting prospect to people
who've never done because I mean you
think you have a great idea but you know
who's going to write you what seems like
a large check for your harebrained idea
right and so when you find these people
how do you start the conversation how do
you go about it and and from your
perspective on this side how if you
think back you know of the last ten
companies you funded where did they come
from you know were they so easily
fundable that you know everybody knew
about them and there was no search or is
there some process that you go through
to kind of find find the diamonds in the
rough Chuck bottom was talk with you
sure well I think one of the easiest
ways is to look at what your early
assets are in terms of the people
involved in the business one of the
things that you hear all the time and
it's true and it's appropriately true as
investors invest in good people and good
teams early on oftentimes you don't have
a team developed yet you can't afford to
hire the best people so what most
companies again do which is very
important as they put together not
necessarily an early board of directors
of a board of advisors people who are
helping them who have industry expertise
so that not only do they help the
company get off the ground and they lend
some credibility on the side of that of
kind of the business side but by and
large they're also going to be some
people who have connections in the
investor community that might have
interest in your type of business for me
that's that was the first path I had an
incredible Board of Advisors made up of
people not necessarily from the food
where
but from consumer goods and from
manufacturing and several of our early
investors not including people I came to
the game no I mean I i I'm 40 years of
45 now by his 41 my started the company
I already had a good community people
that I could call my friends who were
investors but the people outside of that
personal circle they came from my board
of advisers and connections that they
had two angels who had experience
investing in interest investing its
interest in investing in companies like
mine the other thing I did is I took a
look at who was out there as established
angel groups that had consumer goods
experience and had interest in investing
consumer goods companies because again
it's a much smaller community than like
the general technology investing group
that's here in the bay area so it was a
very quick afternoon at the business
school library it took about an hour and
a half to find all of them and it River
how many were there for why is it it
took the rest of the afternoon to
contact him so so again obviously doing
your research whatever industry you're
building a product and they're going to
be people who are out there who want
people to know about them so they'll
find ways through through the industries
and through the investment community to
make themselves known you just have to
find them but the easier path and again
using efficiency the more efficient path
is to use the people who are already
helping you are involved in your
business at other levels to identify
early stage investors yeah i think you
know Sean to hit on a point earlier I
think when you're raising money that you
are selling and I think that selling is
buyers look for low risk and high upside
so you're really creating a story that
demonstrates low risk and high upside
and then you ask you know how do you do
that I don't I don't think you should
ever go cold to an investor I think you
know one of the
Chuck made was you know you you're
always leveraging your network I think
one of our first things we probably
created something that was the precursor
of LinkedIn you know a lot of years ago
really trying to figure out who each of
each person knew when you go out and
start talking to these people there's
there's a piece that you shouldn't lose
it's not just you know calling up your
buddies and who knows whom and what have
you every discussion is an education
somebody's banging a rough corner off of
your idea so when you're having a
discussion with a guy about you know I'm
thinking about doing this or it looks
this way or I should I'm thinking about
going right or left they're telling you
where you're an idiot take that advice
you know don't you know you're going to
talk to 50 people before you actually
make an investor presentation and if you
have your ears open you actually learn
something through every one of those
conversations the second piece that
comes from that is you find an
evangelist you find somebody and I'll
speak for my investor perspective for a
moment but you find somebody that gets
the story and then actually wants to
help you and you'd be amazed at how many
people want to help you you tell them
that she's the story they tell you at
first how much of an idiot you are you
you reshape but you think about
things more you know appropriately and
then that person or those collection of
people actually say I know who might
like this story I got a couple of
friends I think this is right up their
alley so I never and I and I tell you I
I raised money for everything from you
know athletic clubs and did credit card
financing and all the way to like the
owner take back carrying notes on real
estate to Angel money to institutional
money the debt I mean I think I've
covered the whole spectrum in terms of
fundraising and in any one of those
scenarios I never went cold into any
conversation with somebody that had
money somebody was taking me into that
into that meeting okay one good yeah
sure actually Jon Jon has hit on a great
point and this is actually some it's
like a part of the doing the the
pre-work if you will to an investor
presentation you actually never want to
go into one of those legitimate investor
presentations in a position where
they're going to be pointing out what an
idiot you are they will anyways but
do that and they'll do it anyway but but
would you vertical just exactly DJ
ideally you'll find someone to work with
to make the presentation to several
times before you actually go out and
make it for real because there is no
such thing as a perfect business plan
first time out or second or tenth so you
you really do want to prior to talking
to someone who could actually
legitimately invest in your business
have it nailed and the best way to do
that is to have some very very critical
people work through the presentation
with you and there's nothing better than
cave no holds barred okay tearing of
chairing the plan to shreds process
because it really helps mike is what it
sounds like an your end of the table I
mean how do you look for people to
invest in well it's interesting the one
of the things I learned is just get
lucky in the first five years and so the
venture business and increasing return
business and I moved up here from Austin
Texas and just first ave s my maid was
Twitter or the second investment I made
was dig the third investment I made was
you me networks the fourth investment I
made was aggregate knowledge and my deal
flow just exploded and so getting lucky
actually turns out to be important but I
think that the more durable you know
premeditated strategy is to be known for
something and so I think there's there's
too much money in the venture business
too many people investing too few will
make money and so entrepreneurs not just
you but entrepreneurs need to be able to
articulate on the tip of their tongue
why you're different and so you know my
goal was to be the first person you call
if you want to raise between 250,000 and
2 million dollars and if I can if
entrepreneurs play that message back to
me I'm successful if they don't then I
won't get any deals certainly not any
good reason yeah certainly not any good
ones so if we just run the tape back and
we go to
you know before it became easy let's
think about those four first for
investments when you came in you were
not well plug then you said before you
got lucky I don't think I run like that
it's necessarily luck but but but but
we'll take the modesty but I mean at
that point how how are you finding these
investments this this is going to be
embarrassing to but my my son like Star
Wars they want to meet a film them in
the backyard with a lightsaber so I was
rotoscoping blades and adobe photoshop
and I saw a tutorial on digg so I called
up kevin rose and said I'm interested in
your company and he liked that reason
alright so that was like I said it's
pretty random lucky it's not modest have
it right son yeah right have a sun-like
star wars yeah yeah so that but but the
other thing is a little bit less
facetious some investors I think develop
a point of view about what's interesting
and so I think one thing that what that
was an advantage for me was that I was
looking for citizens media type of web
to auto company and I had seen a lot
that I wasn't excited about and so when
I saw this tutorial on digg I was
prepared to receive the inside that it
was interested right I could have seen
it like a thousand other websites but
instantly I knew oh my gosh i'm
interested in citizens media and the
architecture of participation and went
and fortunately when I called Kevin he
thought oh gosh this guy gets it and he
really likes what I'm up to it he cares
about what I care about and so I think
that having an opera re perspective on
what you care about does help and shown
that what what fraction of deals that
you end up doing came of the transom
which we introduce to you I mean how
does that break down really easy 00 of
the transom never you know we
occasionally get one that's interesting
enough that we start looking at it and
whatever reason it's never never
happened it's a very small percentage
that kind of actually get attention
anyway even the ones that have haven't
and so it is all through network and so
one of the tags like that we've used
over the years is we want to be the
point of first referral for the highest
quality entrepreneurs and when we do
that is is we want to make our
reputation in the entrepreneurial
community not that we don't like working
with the rest of the venture community
and you know our brethren as it were but
again you know syndication which is the
process of putting more than one venture
group together and a certain a given
round has comes in and out of favor as
cycles go in and out as capital
requirements come up and down you know
it's back it's dropping out a favor
again because there's relatively little
money required in these early stages so
so we do get deals from other early
stage venture groups that are looking
for somebody that I think John mentioned
that you know there's a certain style to
being an early stage investor you're
looking at different things you you do
need to have a point of view on it on an
industry or set of dynamics that you
believe are gonna in the long run help a
company get from A to B so are we were
hard on our entrepreneurial network and
roughly you know I'd say two-thirds of
the deals we do come through another
entrepreneur who refers the team to us
we have a cap consider a captive group
which is aside fund of successful
entrepreneurs that are actually active
they may be active angel investors maybe
not they may have gotten to a stage in
their career where they they've decided
they don't want to put out a hundred
thousand dollars to everybody who asks
him I mean in the bubble that's kind of
cut if you got you had gotten wealthy
all of your friends in the business
would say hey invest in my company gets
increasingly hard to say no if you
become known as a person who can do that
so some of the guys just channel their
activities through us and then we also
you know repeat entrepreneurs is a
really interesting question because you
know serial entrepreneur is cereal is
successful entrepreneurs there's this
question of well if you hit it big once
are you really motivated to do it again
not that you're not capable but are you
really willing to do what it takes to
get something from zero to several
million dollars because that is really
really hard it's sort of like I built a
deck once
you know actually club no it's a
jackhammer the concrete we saw the laws
and that was it I just never felt the
need to do it again check that off yeah
I checked that box so a lot of times in
and you'll see this a lot of guys who
start coming successfully if it's not a
big enough hit or if they're too young
to retire they'll say you know I want to
do that again but I want to start a
little later in the process you know I'd
like to have some customers and some
revenue so but there are those people
who are just died in the world serial
entrepreneurs they can't get it out of
their system and they're just been hit
over the head once too many times they
love that startup that blank page where
you say okay that one's blegh you know I
can create something from scratch those
guys are awesome there's not a lot of
them on the planet when you find them
you try again to hire you to take your
money so there's that I think that's but
that's how we fight so the
entrepreneurial community if I might
just add one other thing that the good
VCS deal flow is actually their enemy
they see too many deals and so they're
there they're not necessarily looking
for more they're only looking for the
best ones and so I think that the the
other key to recognize that when you get
introduced to a VC when you bring your
plan to avicii their grading you on a
curve there's only so many meanings they
can take it a week and you either make
that cut off or you don't and so I'd
always be asking myself what do I have
to do to make the you know five to ten
cut off list of the deals that they're
going to pay attention to that week and
say you know what I want to reach out to
them and see what they're up to because
if you miss the top 10 list they're not
going to pay attention to you for at
least 90 180 days now that it's really
true it's not it's not some someone
whose name I can't member said you know
if you want me to write a novel yeah I
can get it at the end of the week if you
want me to write a short story it'll
take a couple months it's that that
pitch that elevator pitch which people
you know you say well it's just I can't
possibly tell my story into
minutes well if you can't tell your
story in two minutes it's going to be
really hard so that really second that
so I'm going to just one more question
and then we'll open it up and I think
it's a obvious last question which is
about you know how do you make yourself
attractive and what are you what do you
find attractive and I'm check i'm going
to start with with you I mean I know
what let's talk specifically about the
most recent chocolate how do you sell a
chocolate business well it's actually
embarrassingly easy it's kind of like
the concept and we'll go back to the
idea that in fact I was selling my
company and using the analogy of selling
my product to a whole foods andronico's
whoever it is and we're selling our
product to this is the easiest product
on the planet to sell if you make us a
really superior product I joke that I
don't sell like feet so so the the
process of selling investors on our
product and I should rather on our
company was ridiculously easy I would
introduce them to the product first and
by the time they had had five or six
pieces of chocolate examine the sugar
high didn't hurt but half of the job had
been done for me because in every
process that you go through where you're
trying to find investors you are trying
to convince someone that you actually
have what it takes in terms of product
or service to build a market to create
something special that will basically
return their investment in my business
it was very easy because there aren't
that many there's probably no more than
10 or 15 of us in the entire country
making chocolates at this level and the
people who understand consumer goods and
so many more people now understand
premium tropic understood that
immediately combine that with the fact
that very few of them are business
people I had the advantage of not only
running my own business but running
several other businesses subsequent to
the first that people also recognize
that not only did I have the ability to
create product by probably somewhere had
learn something about business and could
take that and build a business out of it
it's it's a really interesting industry
and that most people get into it our
retired pastry chefs or not retired
pastry chefs chefs and not all of them
have the ability or the wherewithal to
actually build a business around a
product idea so so yeah going back to
the the first statement it was probably
the easiest part of the entire process
was getting the investors interested in
investing in my company so chocolate
wrapped in a term she basically phono is
actually chocolate preceding anything so
our term she was actually written very
early in the process so one of the
things that I and actually this is
another thing one of the things I didn't
want to do is have a whole lot of
different people trying to negotiate
terms so I identified one of our key
investors in our series a very very
early and offered them the opportunity
to work with me with my board of
advisers two of whom became directors
and our lawyer to craft the term sheet
very very early in the process so we
were actually presenting a term sheet to
the line show of the investors rather
than having them come in and feeling
like they had the right to do that for
fifty thousand dollars John you've
raised a lot of money think about a
specific successful instance and what is
it about that um well we fortunately
just close to 15 million dollar round a
couple of fridays ago so it's actually
quite current but I'd say something
before you know talking about the
specific deal I think you know there's a
couple things to remember you know one
is you know you go back to telling that
story you're telling a very attractive
story to somebody to get them excited
about about your venture but but you
have to remember this is a it's a
financial gain
at the end of all the buzz and the hype
and the happiness whatever if somebody
actually has to take their checkbook out
and write you a check for millions of
dollars and so you think about that
process you know in some scenarios like
one of the recent ones i had a champion
at the vc from that i wanted i had to
not only win him over and his partner
there was sort of you know tag team
there but i knew at the end of this
multi-week process i had to win over the
entire investment committee so you're
there's a lot of folks in this process
that you have to get energized about
getting your company funded and got a
picture this and I'll tell you anybody
who's been to the VC offices whether
you're a you know a young entrepreneur
or even later stage they're an
intimidating place I actually believe
they're you know they're an intimidating
place because you know like they said
there's 50 deals that went through there
that week they know they're only going
to get the attention of a couple of
folks even if you have one champion that
really abdicated your store the entire
time you're going to walk into a board
meeting and then six other people that
probably don't genuinely care about you
too may be having a bad day one's not
even in your space but you got six or
seven people around the board and
they're going to go you want me to write
you a check for how many millions of
dollars so i think you gotta really
understand that you're you're asking
somebody for a lot of money and to do
that they expect to get a return from
that so I never lose sight of the ROI
calculation in this whole game as
emotional it as it is as buzz friendly
as it is it's an ROI calculation that
all seven of those folks around that
boardroom we're going to are going to do
before they write you a check and i
think i'd go back to some of the basics
you know the the company that we just
funded i think it's an interesting
scenario and that i actually thought it
was relatively tough and you think about
you know why that was it was a later
stage company so it had already been
around for you know five plus years i
was a new guy that got parachuted into
it
you know already a couple of rounds of
funding had gotten into it so there's
already a couple of big bets up in place
there's millions of dollars into this
thing already I'm going to go back out
to the market and tell collection of
later stage investors that understand
this domain that I have a plan to go
from where we are today and there's
actually you know one of the challenges
about later stage company there's too
much data they actually know where you
are today you know the good bad and ugly
of where you are they have a couple
years of history of that they can go
talk to your customers they can talk to
your partners they can talk to your ex
employees they can talk to your board
they can they can do more homework on
you than you want him to possibly do but
I go back to sort of the original story
I knew when I came into the company that
I always rely on my red dot at the mall
you are here thing I knew where we were
I had to come up with a picture of where
we needed to go and I think on the first
day of entering the company I told the
team exactly what milestones we would
have to achieve just to get a chance to
be fundable right I knew exactly what
we're not I don't mean this like I was
smart but I knew what we needed to do to
be attractive to folks like this and it
took us a year to sort of reposition the
company and do the things that would
make us fundable to the outside investor
community we had to demonstrate that the
technology work we had to demonstrate
the scalability of the SAS model we had
to demonstrate that a growth potential
would come through this partner
distribution channel so we went from
this direct company I won't go to the
details of the company but I'll just
highlight the fact that it was a
transitioning period that we had to get
through in order to reach a milestone
that said I'll write you a check so this
whole growth strategy was via new
partners that weren't proven so you walk
into the VC office and they say that's a
good strategy that's a great way to grow
the company come back a couple quarters
from now when you show me that that
stuff's working so you had this sort of
history that you were trying to get over
and the future that looked cool but sort
of a show me after you you know after it
starts to work a little bit and and then
you're stuck in the middle sort of
needing
cash today to make payroll so I think we
did a fairly decent job of focusing the
entire company on the things that
demonstrated the fundament know us being
fundable we demonstrated the scale the
common company we demonstrated the
traction in the partner channels and the
folks that we presented it to got that
story champion dust took us through the
process and then ultimately you know
wrote us a check for 15 million so it
worked but there was and I'd say this it
was a you know some guys get lucky I
have not you know they go in there and
somebody's offered on a term sheet on
day one we worked for a year to get the
company to a fundable state and then we
got you know then we got the funding and
that was a you know even that was a
multi-month process thank you so my
concern from from your perspective
someone's lucky enough to make it into
the firm and they get to pitch what is
it you're looking for up two or three
things I'll see okay so first of all I
think I'll go back to the I think the
first order is is a big problem so
really the the first thing it's going to
some even call it the marketplace I like
to think of in terms of the problem
space there's got to be a big pain point
that you're trying to solve that that
for one reason another you know people
are willing to spend money on it could
be a proxy could be indirect but it's a
big problem that they can go to solve
secondly people that are if not uniquely
at least in short supply qualified to
solve that problem so that's the domain
expertise that's finding people that
know something about the space actually
know quite a lot about the space I
really don't like investing in teams
that come from another another
marketplace and say yeah I'm not from
this marketplace but I've looked at it
I've studied it for the last couple
months and broom I I got it chances are
it looks good because you don't know
enough about it it's the guys that
really know a space well and are still
willing to start a company in it there
was food ones you want and then the
third thing really and it is in this
order which is tough for a particularly
engineering or product Orion people to
hear is and the third thing in order is
the solution
that's been being proposed and what we
look for is something that is
protectable in some way doesn't have to
be patents it can be trade secrets or
know-how or just something elegant
unique that hasn't been thought of
before it typically is timing dependent
that interaction between particularly
technology sometimes you know a solution
that you just couldn't build five years
ago I know that either that the the
components weren't there or the building
blocks of the software standpoint
weren't there you know the web to do
stuff you couldn't do that five years
ago you didn't have the lamp stack that
you could build an app on top of for
less than a half a million dollars so I
think those three things are what we
look for and another way again I like to
put this analogy to sales cycle and one
of the one of the many sales processes
that are out there is you have to
convince a customer why they need to buy
anything that's that the markets big
enough for the pain points big enough to
matter why do they want to buy you your
your solution so again that's the people
and why do they want to buy now if you
get those three things down the sales
situation then you get somebody to write
your check same thing you're selling a
company at a bigot of pain point with
people that know how to solve it and a
product that is timely for some reason
the reason why it hasn't come to market
before there's a reason why you can
build it now yeah the largely follow
some of the same criteria but the only
thing I might add is that I think the
way you make money is an investor's to
be non consensus and right and so
because there's too much money being
consensus and right you can make soso
returns if you're wrong you lose money
regardless and so being non consensus
and right is what you look for and so
whenever I make an investment I hope
that I can articulate on the tip of my
tongue what is it that we know as a team
that the world doesn't understand yet
and if I can't articulate that with
confidence and precision I usually can't
invest that's a good one of the options
available to non tech entrepreneurs
specifically early stage okay because
later stage they become much more
conventional but early stage again it's
not that the funding options are
different whether it's angels angel
groups or other traditional investors
it's that for consumer products are non
tech products it's just a smaller
community so so for us and for most of
my peer group that I know has kind of
raised money recently there are angel
groups that have an expertise in
consumer products or have partners with
expertise in consumer products so that
was the first place we went because we
knew if we could get a hearing with them
and if we could get one of those groups
to take an interest in the company it
would be that much easier to attract
individual investors a lot of early
stage investment is individuals
especially when you're looking at
500,000 to two million dollars you're
not really at a stage regardless where
VC firms going to really big much
interest in what you're doing so you're
looking at smaller individual and angels
individual investors and angels so again
they're out there it's just a very very
small percentage of the overall
investment community in terms of
identifying them again it's all about
building a network that has access to
those people again it's a small enough
subset of the investment community that
pretty much everyone knows them also a
lot of people that I know who invest in
technology businesses exclusively were
the ones who referred me to some of our
early stage investors because they all
knew it's like oh yeah but here's this
guy over here he doesn't really do my
name is our tech deals but he loves toy
companies packaged food companies
whatever it is and that's really how you
find them it's really just building a
network
it's really into the entire story
succinctly in five minutes you will
distinguish yourself from eighty to
ninety percent of the other companies
that are there Bridget oh yeah that's
funny if it's a technology company you
just have to be able to describe what it
does very clearly and why it's you know
why it's better different unique so the
three things I said what the pain is why
you've solved it now in that format you
don't really have to create your bona
fides you know you don't have to you
don't have to introduce your team you
just have to speak knowledge be enough
that people this is just a this is just
a ticket right you just want the
investors in the room to come up to you
afterwards and say I'd really like to
hear more about your your business
that's your goal right you're not trying
to walk out there with the check you
want you want the right to go in and
spend an hour with X number of these
people
why would someone want to conventional
Bank the question is why bc supposed to
supposed to Vegas Wow um okay filled two
things one banks are very unlikely to
give money to a startup that has no
revenue I'm stuck what fraction of the
companies you fund do you get zero
better or roughly third long period of
time and early-stage fun it's going to
be roughly a third there are no turn a
third pay for everybody else and third
the middle or you know tweeners 2 to 3
x's thanks my life thanks don't like
that thanks at all about assets and cash
flow you don't have cash flow yeah
vision not so much syphilis it's very
much just a little crazy start up there
are multiple stages and a different
opportunities to get funding what is a
good stage to go to a QC in what kind
the way I like to look at it is there
there's a there's a stage in a company
where you're doing customer discovery
before you're doing customer validation
this goes back to customer development
thinking and these days it costs very
little to figure out if you solve a
problem that somebody will pay for and
if you actually solve a big enough
problem people should be willing to pay
for a half-done product i mean i
remember when i was at motive we charged
people $50,000 for the right to receive
alpha software someday and the reason
that we did that was we wanted to
understand whether we really solved a
big problem or not because i was about
to spend five years of my life in the
foxhole bleeding bullets flying around
some idea and so my belief is that not
enough entrepreneurs go to VCS with a
validated proposition that customers
will care about they they go to VCS and
just want to shoot the bull and say hey
do you think this is a good idea or not
and heck of AI know if it's a good idea
right I'm not a customer and so the
answer to whether it's a good idea or
not is always outside the building and
so the degree to which you can come with
facts and rather than opinions about
whether customers will pay and how much
they'll pay and how valuable it is I
think is a big thing the the other
general rule of thumb I have when I make
a stage investment is we should raise
enough money so that we have six months
of cash after we've proven something big
because I want us to be able to approach
the venture of people from a position of
strength and I want them to know that if
they slow roll us will just move on and
that will easily get funded and it turns
out that's actually good for the VCS as
well the VCS want to fall in love with a
company and get straight to due
diligence and get on with life they
don't want to come up with ten reasons
to give the slow no and so those are the
two things I really look for shuttle we
do you'd like to come
in the three change well you know we're
a little bit were a little bit earlier
stage than something an early stage get
got to be mean almost anything except
the mezzanine round but we will do
anywhere from a couple hundred thousand
dollars to a million dollars in student
investment each partner can only do one
of those a year so we don't do it's not
all of what we do but we'll go from a
very much of seed thing our first round
is going to be typically let's say three
to five million dollars for company that
has a product and has some customer
validation when evaluating technology
companies do you have a preference for
product versus platforms in other words
of product somebody has a defendable
market customer base and problem that
solves or the platform which can be
applied to a number of different product
areas potentially definite its
reactivity preference on which one
you're at sea
for us it's really it's sort of the
vision thing versus the go-to-market
strategy platforms are great in theory
but they're also that thing yet most
people think you can't explain inside a
two-minute horizon so ideal ideal the
ideal thing for me really is something
that has the potential will be a
platform and has a very specific go to
market application product that that
people want to buy today I couldn't
agree more there's there's there's two
things that two conversations that
bugged me that happen a lot that I could
just think or false the first is we're
platform yeah and I think every great
platform I've ever seen successful
features and products begat having a
platform yeah nobody started with a
premeditated gold be platform the second
thing that bugs me is when people talk
about their brand early and so I don't
think that Larry and Sergey were saying
oh gee what's the google brand going to
be i think that success begets a brand
rather than the other way around in
silicon valley and that these meetings
that go on in boardrooms or they say we
need to be some brand early-stage just a
waste of time partners you have a small
shop company you're talking to various
different partners do you have to have
an actual contract in play or if you
have a letter of intent when looking for
vc funding i just want to talk to the
person and see if they're it's super
excited or if they're just being the
puppet of the entrepreneur to save and
things to get me to invest but usually
you can detect how passionate that the
partner a customer really is and that's
what rot drives me is this idea that
somebody's invented something the
customers are so passionate about they
just can't quit talking about they just
feel like you have to be
doing business with this person yeah
contracts can be related it's people
behind them making a contract in place
up a lot of starters you'll get in
trouble with a land of big fish right
they'll get a deal with a large company
and then they realize that that company
is actually much worse than they are at
actually performing on the contract I
have a huge example of that by the way
when i was at motive we had a 15 million
dollar deal with one of the big pc oems
we had a rock-solid contract no
contingencies and so then the meltdown
happens in 2001 and I go have a meeting
with them and they say we're not going
to pay you and I said well what are you
talking about we've done everything in
the contract you're not saying you're
unhappy we're just not to pay you we
change their minds we don't want to
deploy your product anymore and I said
well you know you owe us the money it
gets the offering dot painting and they
said they said well do you see it this
guy was from Houston and so the guy goes
like you see that building next door and
I said yeah it goes it's full lawyers
how many lawyers you got and I realized
right I didn't have a lot of money to
spend on lawyer suing a huge
multi-billion dollar conglomerate pc OEM
and so you know contracts with howard
contingencies aren't so contractual in a
downturn so that was tough 15 million
bucks tough to have go away
how do you see a release to discard up
pursuing M&A strategy excuse me versus
organic growth so do you think is good
or do you do have concern when you see
that kind of company hi tech company in
pursuing M&A deals versus organic growth
it's kind of it's a very unusual
situation to be having a strategy to
grow by acquisition you need a currency
if you're not funded so I early-stage
people so you're not funded you then
you're gonna be acquiring the stock and
if you haven't been funded then it's
hard to set a value on that stock so
roll-ups without you know prior to
funding or I pretty emotional yeah also
keep the other thing is private private
mergers are really difficult easier if
there's no venture money involved
frankly but doing doing private mergers
religious free just promise a lot of are
they talking about post-merger
integration or what was so difficult
private private merger the investors on
either side both think their company is
worth more than the other one it's
really just getting investors to create
at a price to merge the organizations
and then of course the CEOs are the
teams on each side think that they
should be running fine okay so ya gotta
merge people and you've got emerged
valuations again without venture
investment when it's angel section a
little easier those they kind of come
together be more easily but you know
chama talking about having 70 panel room
one of the things about venture which is
actually true is that there's a lot of
really smart people with even bigger
egos and so she got to city
two different companies that have not
quite made it on their own so they're
looking let's get bigger and this was
very true in the last three four years
size really has mattered more because
the IPO level that he'll window is
really you know you want bigger
companies so a lot of VC is looked
around you know I said were smart people
so we go okay we need bigger Cup means
how to get big you get the number one
and number two in a space you merge them
together and now you have the clear
leader where you have the number two in
the number three you're now the leader
go public problem is you get two sets to
capitalizations two sets a lot of these
companies were funded at the bubble
they've got 30 40 50 million in capital
in them and everybody's trying to figure
out how how that money is going to get
merged together and what the outcome is
going to be just it's really hard to get
people to agree yeah in my experience
there are no mergers there are only
acquisitions and then some if it's not
clear who's acquiring and who's getting
swallowed it doesn't work and given
those scenarios you know Facebook goes
buys up a little bitty apps developer I
think that can work but if it's company
a and it may be part of it exactly but
if company a company b think that
they're about to get to a merger of
equals look out Mosin is on your table
do you look at it or says
we're going to show this company in five
minutes 90 and we got to go out here
with it this is something I feel pretty
strongly about I don't believe I have
the ability to predict how company is
going to do if it's if it's sufficiently
disruptive and innovative there aren't a
lot of comparables you have a sense that
there's a huge potential market but it's
more like potential energy right if it's
if it's an obvious big market then
that's not a good deal either and so the
way I look at exit is not as a number
but as a probability distribution curve
and whenever a company is raising money
I go to the entrepreneur and I ask okay
well what what exits do you want to
eliminate with this financing round
because if you because the fact the
matter is upstream investors are going
to expect a certain return and if you if
you go raise money at a 50 million
dollar valuation you're not going to
have a 25 million dollar exit where you
make money or even a
fifty-million-dollar exeter probably not
even a hundred-million-dollar exit so I
try to help the entrepreneur have very
good facts about what the probability
distribution curve of exits has been
from 0 1 208 and then based on that take
your strategic choice about how much
money you want to raise and at what
prices and let's let's let's make the
probabilities and the curve play to our
advantages rather than be something that
we have to be captive to really good
point you know when you take additional
financing you are opening doors and
closing doors at the same time you know
if you have an opportunity that can be
accelerated or leverage by additional
capital that's opening up new doors but
you are you are closing off other other
options other opportunities the other
thing I would say is this is an old
maximum which i think is very true as
companies successful companies are
bought not sold if you go into your
company say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
going to put this together to flip it
it's you're not going to get a
as good an outcome as you say we're
going to build a great company here and
chances are if you look over the history
of tech investing chances are somebody
will come along and offer you a good
price for it that's a viable alternative
to going public and then you have a
great decision to make at this point I
think we're standing between you and
chocolate which is never a good place to
be and so please join me in thanking